next question today hey David many of
the top contenders for the Democratic
2020 nomination are pretty old I'm not
being ageist but should Democrats
consider age when they choose their 2020
candidate the answer is yes in the sense
that age is a reasonable factor to
consider right Bernie Sanders I'm going
from memory but in 2020 or maybe at the
time of the inauguration roughly I don't
know Bernie's going to be 79 close to 80
Joe Biden another presumed frontrunner
78 will be Michael Bloomberg who has
switched back to the Democratic Party 78
I believe would be at the time John
Kerry would be in his in his upper 70s
even though he said he doesn't have any
plan to run Elizabeth Warren would be 71
which which is comparatively young
relative to these other contenders this
is arguably more about perception than
it than it is in terms of the impact as
far as actual health most of these
individuals to the extent that we know
are probably as healthy if not healthier
than Donald Trump who is obese quite
frankly or borderline obese by by within
a pound or two of being borderline obese
depending on which numbers you believe
it's very unhealthy has a very unhealthy
lifestyle so it's not really about the
impact that age would have on their
ability to do the job for me it's more
about the perception to need to change
the guard of the Democratic Party the
quote old guard of the Democratic Party
and by that I mean people who have been
around for a while but also just people
who are older and haven't necessarily
been around as long like Elizabeth
Warren they are seen as part of the
problem of what happened in the 2016
Democratic primary fairly or unfairly I
would argue in some cases fairly in some
cases a little bit less fairly Bernie
Sanders of course the exception to that
because he was the victim of what
happened in the 2016 Democratic primary
other than Bernie I'm not sure that
anybody on that list really gives the
perception of changing the guard I know
Elizabeth Warren's political positions
are almost as left as Bernie's but she
has seen much more as establishment
Massachusetts Democrat all
because of her background her corporate
background then Bernie Sanders is
Bloomberg used to be a Democrat now is
back to being a Democrat there's not too
many more establishment type people than
Michael Bloomberg he's another super
rich old white guy and that's the sort
of you need another guy like Trump to
fight Trump but Trump would mop the
floor with Michael Bloomberg quite
frankly rhetorically with his insult
games in his tweets and his nicknames
but Democrats shouldn't fall for the
hole we need a fresh-faced youngster
thing because it resonates really loudly
with other young voters the idea of I
mean I don't think anybody's talking
about Alexandria Castillo Cortez running
for president but other Young Democrats
Joaquin Castro for example I don't know
who else but you need votes from
Democrats and moderates independence in
a lot of parts of the country where
those youngsters are not going to be as
appealing now without endorsing anyone I
don't even know who's running OK but I
understand the appeal of someone like
sherrod Brown strategically he's
interesting because he won't be close to
80 at the time of the inauguration he's
in his mid sixties right now he has
experience he's a reasonable progressive
he's not the most progressive guy but
he's a reasonable progressive he's from
the Midwest which will appeal to another
set of voters and he would not be
subject to successful attacks against
him along certain lines that some other
people would now politically I still
line up way more you know where I'm
going with Bernie Sanders and I would be
likely to support Bernie Sanders and in
the primary if you ran but there's a
part of me that's wondering about
sherrod Brown although it's unclear if
he can can't handle Trump's games and
that is an open question